[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le
cetud journal de tv 60,18 l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale et régionale en 26
minutes tout de suite les titres de ce
mardi à 9 avril
les pompiers de magny les hameaux ce
matin à guyancourt le site d'aînés
disent les recevait pour une formation
objectif comprendre le fonctionnement
des installations électriques afin de
mieux réagir en cas d' à 110 une visite
dans le cadre d'un partenariat entre
l'entreprise et le service départemental
d'incendié et de secours des yvelines un
centre de recherche et de développement
autour de l'intelligence artificielle
ibm a inauguré hier les premiers locaux
de son futur site à orsay et le géant
américain entend travailler avec
l'université paris sud et les
entreprises implantées sur le plateau
une inauguration en présence notamment
du secrétaire d'état au numérique
cedrico et puis c'est ce samedi et
dimanche la maison de l'environnement de
magny les hameaux accueille un week-end
100% cultures urbaines au programme
shows chorégraphiques hip hop et battle
solidaire elle nous en parlons avec nos
deux invités jamal mou mou et jean jemaa
sur ce plateau est également tout à
l'heure à nita berdougo coauteur du
jardin intérieur de l'est est un album
illustré sur l'éveil émotionnel ce
chiffre pour commencer deux cent
soixante quatorze le nombre de violences
sexuelles enregistrés dans les yvelines
au premier trimestre 2010 9
ces données qui comprennent les
agressions et les viols viennent d'être
dévoilés par le ministère de l'intérieur
enseignement un nombre d'affaires record
depuis 2015 ou 149 faits avaient été
recensés sur la même période à nuancer
tout de même le ministère constate que
cette augmentation est aussi dû aux
affaires judiciaires qui sont de plus en
plus à présenter donc devant la justice
le la parole qui se libèrent chez
beaucoup de femmes
on prend tout de suite la direction de
guyancourt des pompiers de la caserne de
magny les hameaux se sont rendus ce
matin dans les locaux des nedis le but
de la visite comprendre le
fonctionnement du site et agir plus
rapidement sur le terrain le récit de
mickaël millero
c'est une première pour les pompiers de
magny les hameaux neuf d'entre eux se
sont rendus ce mardi 9 avril sur le site
du distributeur électrique est née 10 à
guyancourt dans le cadre d'un
partenariat
ils ont découvert à cette occasion un
poste source un grand transformateur qui
permet d'abaisser la tension électrique
objectif créer une coopération pour la
prévention des risques pour leur
expliquer le chemin de l'électricité à
quel moment et bien on peut être amené à
intervenir nous pour couper
l'électricité si jamais il ya un risque
important sur une zone et de quelle
façon les pompiers pourront intervenir
avec notre appui en cas d'incident
pendant la visite les visages sont
concentrés les responsables des dix sont
présentés pendant toute la matinée les
différents secteurs de ce site qui
dessert l'électricité dans la zone de
saint quentin en yvelines et de
versailles
ça ne sert à rien normes et ment donc
déjà de voir concrètement le site son
fonctionnement et après d'avoir un
échange avec les acteurs on va dire un
échange physique avec avec les acteurs
et ça c'est toujours très intéressant
c'est un vrai plus et c'est toujours
mieux quand on comprend bien les choses
voilà et sur les interventions ça peut
nous aider également ce type de visite
est organisée une à deux fois dans
l'année dans le cadre d'un partenariat
renouvelé tous les trois ans politique
locale les électeurs de vernouillet vont
devoir très prochainement retourner aux
urnes des élections municipales
anticipées doivent se tenir dans la
commune de près de 10000 habitants
conséquence de la démission hier de 15
élus de la majorité municipale en
désaccord avec le maire dvd pascal
collado et l'édile dispose plus
désormais d'assez de colistiers pour
remplacer les conseillers frondeurs un
futur centre de recherche et
développement en rupture l'intelligence
artificielle le groupe ibm en a inauguré
hier ses premiers locaux à orsay en
présence de deux secrétaires d'état une
stratégie orientée vers les partenariats
avec l'université paris saclay et le
tissu économique du plateau les détails
de nicolas d'ombré rechercher des
solutions pour intégrer de
l'intelligence artificielle dans
l'activité des entreprises
c'est l'objectif de ce nouveau centre de
recherche et développement 10 bm france
implantée sur le cluster paris saclay le
géant américain de l'informatique
travaille notamment avec le groupe
guerbet spécialiste de l'imagerie
médicale
la collaboration avec d'autres
entreprises un axe stratégique pour ibm
france
or l'idée c'est travailler sur
l'imagerie médicale et de commencer à
construire des outils qui vont permettre
aux radiologues de faciliter sa tâche
dans la détection la caractérisation des
cancers ou trouve une silicon valley à
la française où il ya toutes les
entreprises qui vont bien et donc en
fait beaucoup des projets qui sont à
venir sont à inventer
mais le fait qu'on soit là on va pouvoir
tisser les liens qui vont bien pour
pouvoir créer justement cette valeur est
aussi créé les compétences de demain
parce qu en ouvrant nos laboratoires en
ouvrant nos portes en travaillant avec
l'écosystème d'envoi aussi permettre à
certains de faire des choses qui
pouvaient pas faire auparavant dans cet
écosystème économique il ya aussi
l'université de paris saclay elle
propose déjà des filières sur
l'intelligence artificielle
cette nouvelle implantation va renforcer
la collaboration avec ibm france et la
mobilité des étudiants vers la recherche
en entreprise
avec aussi un impact sur les étudiants
non seulement à travers les stages à
travers l'apprentissage mais aussi la
sensibilisation à l'entrepreneuriat
on est de toute façon sur une vie namik
de réflexion pour la formation de
l'intelligence artificielle et c'est
clair que le partenariat avec ibm va
nous aider à développer de nouvelles
filières et de nouvelles orientations
hexion doigt pour des raisons
économiques souveraine et pour des
raisons de modèle de société permettent
en france d'émerger les champions
d'intelligence artificielle que ce soit
l'ofs dans la capacité à développer de
l'intelligence artificielle aussi dans
les usages le gouvernement prévoit
d'investir 1 5 milliard d'euros dans
l'intelligence artificielle sur
l'ensemble du quinquennat
de son côté ibm france construit
actuellement un autre bâtiment pouvant
accueillir 350 personnes
la petite pause à présent dans ce
journal pour vous présenter ce livre un
album illustré d'éveil émotionnel le
jardin intérieur de léa c'est une auto
édition parue fin 2018 coécrit par sarah
berd au goût et par vous anita berdougo
bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes tard est thérapeute
énerve énergétique est aussi artiste
peintre habitante du pec et vous avez
donc publier ce livre avec votre fille
ça c'est un ouvrage qui parle des
émotions chez l'enfant quel est
l'objectif quel message vous voulez
passer avec cet ouvrage on voulait
participer au changement des mentalités
et à l'évolution du monde
en ce moment on se rapproche de la
nature on sera on se rapproche du
respect de la bienveillance et c'est ce
qu'on avait envie de faire et en
particulier chez les enfants
parce que les enfants sont les adultes
de demain et en apprenant aux enfants à
respecter leurs émotions à respecter
qu'ils sont respectés leurs besoins ils
apprendront à respecter les autres à
respecter la nature et on viendra
peut-être un jour dans un monde de paix
n'ont qu'à prendre finalement à l'enfant
à reconnaître et prendre soin de ses
émotions pourquoi cette thématique de
l'émotion et est importante pour
l'enfant pourquoi les reconnaître les
gérer ses émotions pourquoi cette
thématique et est importante parce que
quand on travaille uniquement avec son
cortex on apprend à faire des choses
quand on fait appel à ses émotions on
apprend à vivre selon selon vraiment sa
propre personnalité
on est plus à l écoute de soi en étant
plus à l'écouté de soi on peut être plus
à l'écouté des autres et cohabiter avec
nos différences et sur le titre le
jardin intérieur de l'oea pourquoi
l'avoir nommé comme ça le livre parce
qu'on a utilisé la métaphore du jardin
le jardin qui est en rapport avec la
nature avec la connexion
avec les animaux les fleurs les saisons
qui sont à la fois changeantes présente
et qui peuvent changer d'une minute à
l'autre
comme nos émotions qui ont des couleurs
extraordinaires qui ont des potentiels
extraordinaire pour peu qu'on les laisse
s'exprimer
exactement comme ce qu'on peut vivre à
l'intérieur de soi alors je disais tout
à l'heure c'est un ouvrage co écrit avec
votre fille sarah qui est coach pour
enfants et adultes et qui bat beaucoup
son travail sur l'éducation positif
pourquoi vous avez choisi de mener ce
travail à 2 pourquoi c'était aussi
important pour vous devait le mener à
deux ce travail en fait on a commencé un
processus d'évolution personnelle toutes
les deux en même temps et puis ça a
suivi un peu à l'intérieur de la famille
et on a voulu partager ensemble nos
connaissances dans ce domaine
voilà toujours avec la même idée de
faire avancer le monde
qu'est ce qu'il contient du coup cet
ouvrage il ya du texte de l'illustration
également voilà du texte de
l'illustration et des outils mais les
outils c'est apprendre aux enfants
justement à voilà comment faire pour
reconnaître écouter ses émotions
donc les outils c'est des graines qu'on
va se met alors les enfants vont semer
les graines en utilisant ce livre et
puis nous les parents les enseignants
les pédopsychiatres les psychologues
tous ceux qui sont en relation avec
l'enfant en lisant ce livre on venir
comme ça se met les premières irène chez
l'enfant sur le travail préalable pour
cet ouvrage alors appel c'est une
autoédition ça veut dire vous avez eu
des difficultés à trouver des maisons
d'édition pour le publier on s'est posé
cette question maison d'édition ou pas
est en réalité on aurait pu faire les
deux on a pensé que l'auto édition ça
permettait peut-être de créer une
communauté de gens qui étaient sensibles
à la même question que nous et puis de 2
voilà des gens qui seraient intéressés
par notre travail qui auraient envie
d'aller dans le même sens vous avez
d'ailleurs organismes campagne de
crowdfunding pourquoi pas revenir à
publier cet ouvrage ça fonctionne et ça
fonctionnait très bien on a réussi avec
plus de 2 100 % et ensuite on a
commencé des démarches vers les
librairies vers les professionnels et on
continue ses démarches là on fait des
ateliers de lecture également il ya des
enseignants qui ont acheté notre livre
et qui font des ateliers de lecture dans
leur classe ça marche très bien vous
aider a reçu le soutien du psycho
sociologue jacques salomé qui est
renommé sur cette thématique qui a
publié plusieurs ouvrages sur la
question et ça vous a donné j'imagine 1
un soutien supplémentaire ça vous a
conforté dans l'idée d'aller au bout de
ce projet voilà exactement
et puis on est fan de cet auteur est en
fait c'est lui qui a été la base de
notre développement personnel comment
apprendre à s'aimer soi-même pour
ensuite pouvoir aimer les autres et
c'est ce qu'on doit apprendre aux
enfants
du coup il s'adresse à qui se livre plus
aux enfants aux parents à leurs familles
aux professionnels de santé peut-être
s'adresse en fait à tout le monde aux
enfants qu'ils vont être capables de le
lire de façon autonome aux parents qui
vont le lire aux enfants plus petits aux
personnels de santé qui vont pouvoir
amener les enfants qui ont des
difficultés dans le domaine
psychologique à être plus ouverts plus
attentifs à eux mêmes plutôt que d'être
fermée aux enseignants parce qu'on
n'apprend pas que des choses dans le
domaine pratique mais ici dans le
domaine de la vie de tous les jours
donc en fait c'est ouvert à tout le
monde y compris aux adultes qui ont pas
encore pris soin de leurs émotions
qu'ils n'ont pas l'habitude de se poser
la question de comment je me sens
aujourd'hui
alors c'est bien aussi pour eux mais
c'est un outil qui a séduit en tout cas
les professionnels puisque l'ouvragé est
utilisé par l'équipe soignante de
l'hôpital psychiatrique sainte anne à
paris
voilà exactement et donc c'est un outil
qui sert aux enfants qui ont des
difficultés psychologiques de tous
ordres et c'est aussi utile chez les
enfants zèbres qui sont des enfants
hypersensible hyper créatif aux
multiples potentiels mais qui sont pas
toujours reconnus et puis voilà vous
enfants de o'toole et à tous les enfants
du monde entier mais où est-ce qu'on
peut le retrouver
pour le moment cet ouvrage alors on peut
le retrouver sur nos sites respectifs
anita vers d'hugo points comme sarah
berdugo points comme dans quelques
librairies du 78 et de paris je suis en
train de continuer les démarches petit à
petit merci anita berdougo d'avoir été
avec nous sur ce plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes la coauteure avec votre fille
sarah verdugo du jardin intérieur de
disponible au prix de 15 euros et je
vous invite à vous rendre sur les sites
internet qui s'est affichée dans cet
entretien pour avoir plus d'informations
avant de parler culture un mot de sport
trap organise ce week end la deuxième
édition de son semi-marathon c est
dimanche un parcours urbain et surtout
au travers de la nature 80% du tracé
passe par l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines au programme de
l'événement le semi-marathon bien sûr de
21 km est mais aussi une course plus
courte pour tous les niveaux de 10 km
une course jeunes est également proposée
pour les jeunes la journée démarre dès 9
heures et sera rythmée par un programme
d'animations gratuites autour de
l'athlétisme au stade gilbert gensac
écouter le maire adjoint aux sports à
lire à bay hill était l'invité de
michael et demi d'euros hier dans
l'émission le 7-8 sport la première
édition était une réussite
on a déjà pu enregistré l'année dernière
pour la première édition plus de 320
inscrits pour le 10 km et le
semi-marathon cette année on a déjà
dépassé les inscrits l'année dernière on
est à près de 400 à l'heure où je vous
parle on espère pouvoir faire courir
plus de 500 personnes le dimanche
prochain sur la ville de trappes donc
beaucoup de coureurs viennent parfois de
loin et découvrent ce qu'est le vrai est
rappelé notamment le nouveau trappe
les nouveaux bâtiments qui sortent de
terre les quartiers qui sont rénovés et
donc en faisant circuler cette course
sur 20% du parcours sur le périmètre de
la ville de trappes on permet de briser
un peu les clichés les idées reçues sur
notre commune et on profite à la fois du
parcours urbain dans un cadre
relativement agréable et puis surtout de
cette formidable il est il de loisirs
qui nous permet de courir entre les
arbres sur les sentiers et c'est un vrai
bonheur
les inscriptions en ligne sont ouvertes
jusqu'au 11 avril il sera possible
également de s'inscrire le jour de la
course sous réserve de places
disponibles comptait 14 euros pour le
semi-marathon et 8 euros pour le 10 km
[Musique]
allez on parle culture avant
d'accueillir mai prochain les invités la
culture c'est pour tout le monde cette
semaine à saint quentin en yvelines bon
sens mélanie poker alors pour le coup de
coeur culture vous parlez du baby âge
qui se déroule depuis le 6 avril et
médiathèques la baby pour les tout
petits c'est ça alors l'instant des tout
petits ne cesse de grandir grégory là
aujourd'hui sept ans mais comme toujours
le mois d'avril va tourner autour du
livre de la petite enfance des comptines
et la responsable de ce festival nous
rappelle son but
on trouve très peu de spectacle sur la
petite enfance
certains parents imaginent que les
enfants me livre ils ne savent pas
parler les livres n'est pas important
pour eux alors qu'on se rend compte à
chaque fois que ça éveille 200 tas de
choses alors babillage mélanie se
déroule jusqu'au 20 avril et c'est dans
toutes les médiathèques de
l'agglomération
oui et cette année le thème c'est le
corps et c'est le mouvement alors il ya
de nombreux rendez-vous des comptes et
des comptines bien sûr mais aussi des
ateliers où les parents peuvent
apprendre à signer un moyen pour
communiquer autres mois que son enfant
et enrichir aussi la relation adulte
enfant pour ce rendez-vous direction la
médiathèque du canal à
montigny-le-bretonneux le samedi 13
avril à 14 heures le français signé se
décline aussi en raconte yen cette fois
ça se passe le samedi 20 avril à
maurepas et à elancourt pour les plus
timides aussi pourquoi ne pas vous
laisser tenter par les spectacles où il
y aura des histoires d'acrobates de
clones de souris et de cochons mais des
rendez vous à vivre en famille pour ne
rien rater on fonce tout de suite sur le
site kiosque point est-ce qu y point fr
mais la nuit on vous retrouve dans un
instant dans un set 8 culture un peu
spécial ce soir on fête les 50 ans
d'ouverture au public du château de
breteuil et pour l'occasion le marquis
en gris françois de breteil nous a
ouvert les portes de son domaine nous
venons ainsi sur l'histoire de ses 50
ans mais nous allons aussi découvrir
quelques noms célèbres de la famille et
c'est ce qui fait sa popularité
aujourd'hui les contes de perrault et
ses jardins à 7,8 cultures spéciales à
retrouver bien sûr à la fin de ce
journal après ce journal merci mélanie
on continue à parler culture plus
précisément cultures urbaines magny les
hameaux leur consacre un week-end deux
jours de shows chorégraphiques hip hop
et battle solidaire qui se déroule à la
maison de l'enduit
pour en parler deux invités à ma gauche
d'amalou et jean djoman bonsoir à vous
deux jamal vous êtes le directeur de
l'association h2v qui co organise le
programme et jean djoman vous êtes bien
sûr le cofondateur de la compagnie black
blanc beur vous allez nous parler d'un
projet musique et danse qui est menée en
ce moment et dont une partie d'ailleurs
sera présenté lors de ce week-end dédié
aux cultures urbaines jahren ou un mois
déjà sur votre association h dauger ça
veut dire hip hop de givre c'est une
association de gif-sur-yvette exacte et
en essonne
c'est ça exactement donc hip hop de gif
pourquoi il y avait le côté scientifique
donc les 2h de hip hop et donc on a fait
un petit jeu de mots c'est devant devenu
et h2 j'ai donc ça fait dix ans que
cette structure existe et du coup
maintenant on est un peu indépendant on
a nos propres locaux nos studios de
danse et donc on fait tout ce qui tourne
autour des cultures urbaines que ce soit
la partie danse comme ce week-end à
magny les hameaux mais aussi le côté
street art deejaying et c'est tout les
toutes les disciplines qui tourne autour
des cultures
donc c'est plus globale sur les cultures
urbaines exactement il ya quoi il ya des
courses 5,7 alors on a des coups ont
narré 400 adhérents sur sur la structure
après il ya des choses qui sont en
dehors des cultures urbaines
mais la majorité des cours dispensés sur
place sont de la danse hip hop de dd
mélange aussi comme le bollywood fusion
etc avec des connu des commandes ird et
dynamique un peu hip hop mélangé à
d'autres danses ethniques mélange de mad
les black blanc beur on ne les présente
plus la compagnie l'une des compagnies
pionnières du hip hop en france des
jeunes qui ont pris la suite des blacks
blancs beurs c'est les baies 3 juniors
alors c'est effectivement la dernière
équipe à avoir été formés
professionnaliser série b 3 juniors en
effet et une partie de cette équipe à
démarrer un processus de création dans
le cadre de l'opération menée à meunier
les hameaux et donc voilà ça va faire
l'objet d'une présentation d'un deux
premières étapes
disons de création on en dit amo juste
après déjà mal votre association qu
organise ce week-end 100% culture
urbaine le l'objectif à la base c'est
quoi alors
objectif c'est d'allier la partie
professionnelle c'est à dire mettre en
avant des compagnies qui qui tourne un
peu en région parisienne et que je
trouve pas assez donc du coup et le
mélange est aussi à la pratique amateur
voilà et il ya une partie est aussi
solidaire donc avec des associations
comme la main tendue qui vient gérer la
partie restauration parce que ils font
tout ce qui est maraudes et c est le
dimanche la partie battle donc on va
pouvoir accéder aux battles on va plus
on va amener des denrées alimentaires
des produits de première nécessité pour
les restos du coeur voilà donc on allie
le côté solidaires au niveau 2 du
week-end complet et une partie vraiment
artistiques professionnels et amateurs
donc le fait de les mélanger c'est de
tirer les amateurs plus vers le vert le
professionnel c'est une chance pour les
amateurs de pouvoir côtoyer ces
professionnels etc te ment d'être en
première partie des pros et voilà et
c'est quelque chose que j'essaie de
faire tourner un peu sur plusieurs
communes pour justement à allier encore
vous dis c'est ce côté et mix entre
l'amateur et lepron parce que souvent on
a des plateaux où on vient voir des
professionnels mais donner la chance
aussi aux pratiques amateurs
je trouvais que c'était assez
intéressant il donc magny les hameaux
était assez friands de ce genre de
projet une association de deux gifles
mais qui rayonne on le voit au travers
de cette présence à magny les hameaux et
rayonne dans plusieurs villes
oui ou non de vie fonctionne avec ce
même genre de procédé sur des communes
aussi dans le sud-ouest à bayonne par
exemple on a essayé de faire des choses
aussi à l'étranger parce qu'on fait des
échanges culturels
donc on a vraiment aucune limite sur sur
notre nos interventions et voilà magny
les hameaux fait partie de la suite de
ces deux cdc petits projets qu'on met en
place un peu partout alors présentons le
programme déjà sur la soirée du samedi
ça démarrera 20h30 exactement donc 20h30
et justement en ouverture nous aurons le
travail de création
dernière étape que j'avais tout à
l'heure donc c'est un projet musique et
danse les semaines avec les associations
trois as tu parce qu'après c'est par
l'essentiel du programme c'est le début
il a beaucoup pas des lires turques
absolument noma c'est vraiment un projet
qui ressemble à ce qu'on essaie de faire
depuis le début c'est à dire au delà de
la danse et de la forme qui nous donne
prétexte à nous rencontrer
en fait c'est encore un récit qui va se
tisser entre des habitants des habitants
trappe des habitants manie moi c'est ce
qui m'apporte véritablement ce qui
m'importe c'est qu'il ya des récits qui
se tissent que ces récits puisse on
puisse les esthétisé c'est à dire amener
à des ad plan symbolique à des plans
artistique qui touche vraiment le plus
grand nombre et je pense qu'à ce moment
là la fonction spectacle est
véritablement la plus utile la plus
efficace possible
donc là c'est un processus qui démarre
je pense c'est la première année il est
prévu sur trois ans et il va s'élargir à
d'autres partenaires parce que ce qui
est important c'est que et toutes sortes
d'habitants alors là l'enjeu cette fois
ci c'est des musiciens qui
habituellement sont derrière leurs
instruments
un peu pas forcément un sens de l'image
qu'ils donnent sur un plateau et des
danseurs qui vont abandonner mélanger
leurs pratiques là aussi on retrouve des
amateurs et des professionnels
naturellement mais ça n'est pas
simplement comment dirais je
ce clivage est enrichissant mais je
pense que ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'est ce qui se produit au bout de
trois ans quel genre d'histoire vont
rester après le spectacle entre des gens
de trappes et des gens de manille je
pense que c'est ça faire l'histoire d'un
territoire en place samedi ça sera une
étape de ce projet c'est rare et à les
hanter de ce projet en ce qui me
concerne avec magny-les-hameaux donc à
la demande de deux
xavier goulet et d'émilie dubuc qui sont
venus vers nous à un moment donné voilà
il avait envie de quelque chose c'est
arrivé aussi des danseurs et des
musiciens à ce truc c'est pas quelque
chose qui a été projeté par les grands
penseurs de la culture et moi j'aime
bien quand ça commence cette manière là
duhamel sur la suite de la programmation
samedi
alors moi je veux juste rebondir sur ce
qui l'est aussi parce que je trouve ça
intéressant
ce qui était important aussi dans le
projet ce que ce que j'ai dit aussi à
emilie dubuc justement c'est que ce qui
était important pour nous c'était
d'avoir des locaux
voilà que les locaux s'ils sont intégrés
et du coup d'être avec encore une fois
ces professionnels et d'avoir des
niveaux différents et c'était vraiment
important dans ce projet dans la suite
du programme on va avoir des compagnies
assez connus comme extrêmement bons qui
nous fonde la salsa hip hop on va avoir
à y peines pas ici qui nous revisite la
hype des années 90 et plein d'autres
groupes qui sont là avec plaisir et qui
tournent sur toutes les dates qu'on leur
propose et qui sont qui ont le coeur sur
la main et très rapidement pour le
programme du dimanche de 14 heures à 18
heures là on sera sûr des battles
solidaire exactement c'est à dire les
gens arrivent avec leurs denrées
alimentaires et ensuite se faire plaisir
sur un bateau ou encore une fois on a
une catégorie débutants pour donner
encore l'occasion à des débutants
pouvoir s'exprimer avec un dj andy
djenkana ch'ti qui seront là et qui sera
là au micro et voilà avec d'autres
catégories breakdance et all style à
l'autre bien sûr tout le programme sur
le site internet de magny les hameaux un
week-end 100% cultures urbaines ce
samedi et dimanche à magny les hameaux
et et c'est à la maison de
l'environnement merci de java le mot
mercier jean djoman seat est repassé sur
ce plateau
et puis pour refermer ce journal
imaginer la vie sur la lune à l'aide de
lego c'est le défi qui est lancé à des
jeunes saint quentinois samedi ils
dévoileront leurs travaux pour la first
lego league junior marylène iapichino
s'est rendu au sein d'un atelier
préparatoire c'était à bois d'arcy pour
vivre sur la lune un magasin de quoi on
se pose des questions quelque peu
futuriste au centre de loisirs jean
louis barrault de bois d'arcy depuis le
mois de janvier des apprentis
astronautes volontaires sont entrés en
mission lune et cette année on sent
j'ai à travailler sur l'allégorie donc
ça passe très bien au niveau des
chansons en plus ils travaillent sur
taddei donc c'est d'autant plus
intéressant que sur papier très équipes
se sont formées dans quatre communes de
saint quentin en yvelines
piloté par l'association un genius en
collaboration avec les différents
centres de loisirs elles sont inscrites
à la first lego league
juniors des kits leur sont fournis pour
construire base lunaire et robot adapté
c'est vous c'est vous êtes ingénieur à
moi je pose des questions c'est tôt sur
rencontre bienveillance ou les enfants
ils vont préparer un thème le thème
cette année c'est le 50e anniversaire du
premier pas de l'homme sur la lune eh
bien ce sont ceux là ils vont créer une
base lunaire et ils vont réfléchir à
comment vivre sur la lune comme ça ils
vont apprendre d
des termes techniques mais aussi vont
apprendre à s'exprimer en public parce
qu'il faut qu'ils y défendre leurs idées
les enfants de 6 à 9 ans réfléchissent
et expérimentent comme de vrais
programmateurs ou architectes et j'avoue
que je faisais avancer la voiture pour
pour transporter des mondes et de
l'approvisionnement jusqu'à la base une
aire qu'en train de faire est une espèce
de base et moitié base moitié sas et le
tout pour être prêt pour la rencontre en
finale le samedi 13 avril
et j'ai pas envie que ça cesse car il
est comme les autres équipes qu'il ya
des copains ne reste plus qu'à s'assurer
que tout est bien sécurisée pour pouvoir
s'envoler et vivre sur la ligne c'est la
fin du set 8 journal reportage édition
complète à retrouver sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 dans un instant je vous rappelle ce
rendez-vous un 7,8 culture spéciale
enregistrée depuis le château de
breteuil à choisel c'est avec mélanie
poker et belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]